a
[Música]
ah
honduras ocupó el segundo lugar como uno
de los países con los más altos índices
de impunidad a nivel mundial únicamente
superado por tailandia según el último
estudio realizado por el índice global
de impunidad de los 69 países esta
nación centroamericana estuvo en el
lugar al número 68 con un 59 puntos 69
por ciento
los mayores problemas recaen en su
sistema de justicia y su sistema de
seguridad los resultados de este
análisis convergen también con algunos
miembros de la sociedad civil quienes
consideran que las principales
instituciones del estado de derecho
están siendo mal dirigidas lo que ha
dado lugar a diversos actos de
corrupción que todavía se mantienen
precisamente en la impunidad los mismos
usuarios del sistema de justicia no
creen en la eficacia y además en la
honestidad de los funcionarios los
principales problemas de corrupción que
ha tenido este país tienen que ver con
actos de violencia además con
graves actos de corrupción a nivel
estatal violaciones de los derechos
humanos entre muchos otros
[Música]
paraguay se encuentra entre los 10
países con mayor impunidad en el sistema
judicial en las américas así lo destaca
el índice global de impunidad 2020 que
se dio a conocer días atrás este informe
destaca que la exclusión social es decir
la falta de acceso a la justicia es una
de las principales causas de que
paraguay ocupe este lugar en el ranking
señala también el informe que las
prácticas de corrupción
institucionalizada durante la dictadura
de alfredo strossner de la cual el país
salió hace sólo 30 años formalizó el
sistema bajo el cual hoy funciona el
sistema judicial paraguayo por lo tanto
señalan también que la estabilidad
económica y social del país se ve
afectada y es necesario que urgentemente
se haga una reforma del sistema judicial
paraguayo este reclamo que ahora viene
en un informe internacional es señalado
también desde hace mucho tiempo por
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
locales aquí en paraguay
[Música]
méxico- figura entre los 10 países con
mayor impunidad a nivel mundial al
colocarse en la posición 60 de 69
naciones estudiadas en el índice global
de impunidad 2020 el estudio elaborado
por la universidad de las américas
puebla da a méxico un puntaje de 49
puntos 67 cuando el promedio global es
de 39.99 es decir méxico se ubica por
arriba solamente de países como honduras
argelia o nepal la falla más importante
detectada por el estudio es la
impartición de justicia concretamente la
falta de jueces en relación con la
cantidad de población pues mientras el
promedio mundial es de 18 jueces por
cada 100.000 habitantes en méxico solo
es de 2 al hablar de impunidad el rector
de la udlap la instancia que coordina el
estudio luis ernesto derbez se refirió a
los vídeos del caso lozoya donde se
observan presuntos sobornos a
legisladores el sexenio pasado y
advirtió que si sólo se usan para el
escándalo mediático y no para un proceso
jurídico únicamente favorecerán la
impunidad de la que méxico tanto parece
[Música]